マイリーは久しぶりの
配信
read as rb ファンスィービーチファインダーウェアー
そしてエスティマ無駄な出費もに youtube のアーサー王
電球も冬ああ
美味しいです
マイカーケアじゃない守備 ok
[音楽]
言え can
いやいるそれではマイクさるぱぱ
スパレジアプリディスプレイ
羽田でストーリーも new tube のあーわーさー
スーパー加え
開けば恵ちゃん変えから
ああ減らしベルン
ok
マイクオーリー nice to be 者ステイ
守備おk なん
こんちゃのセンセぺローマ字ペロウェーバー so poor
seasar ドローンマイカー input to do
マイクは聞きましたっけよかったです
道具インクリース暴飲パーフェクティング hb グリーン free ショーツ
フォース pou dou dou
を受けん
パーフェクトだっけ
数点キーオーバー mageia sre have a teraterm 4 at
カーみー ddr 4 not to do so
ハーバー大手マイナーアームストーリー4 f
インクリスト本 headspace アーマーケアー
pas スクリーンタープ to do ある
maybe
今34歳です
ありがとうございますみなさんありがとうございます
まさかの年下まさかってどういうこと
ん
まあメインストーリー fortinet リース x3 boarder ダーク a
young だよ
imedia refman ポーリーズファ
how are you doing
isotope ワーク
nee appears ツアーぷりをベースドラムアウディ a 6オールバーガー
ライスフリー延期 ssd やー
お箸も使えますよ ips # sticks to hurry 存否母性
日本語上手 tu sais chirp セフセフ
ノーウェイクエスト x olde n
えっ
ブーブードゥカーレ宮 pou dou dou
あじゅスパイを冷蔵庫臭
甘みであなたペンキ屋 pcl
5 e 4 fa soapbar asp ポスター具合アグライア author
ijp ニーズ keiso リード g nor re japanese are
you doing
ウェスタリーなぁ相撲ストライカー
ラブリーパッドポスター付祖父 to do モンスター5ベリオスマグでぃんぐ
青 hey
電球 for dear ベッドねぇ線
is からスティック timesten usd sector 9セクターナイン
ドネーション
sde アプリシール2点 cure
スピーカー only japanese please 日本語でもいいです
日本語で話しましょう話しましょうか
見た目で年齢ははから端からなんですそうだよね
neighborhood ネーション ap シーター
その足場キャビン isi have i カップカーピーチたいなず
ウィリー忠義 your free press the doom マーカー mad
voodoo キャビア
ディズニーウィング
なんかミスいい
ん
別審美ペンタぺちゃ
分けなきゃよ
6コーヒーです
おめでとうございます
i have a japanese ber ホップソファ
japanese teacher ソファ japanese for ウィリー
バーボンっ
ターボ d
よくないな
rr rearrange アーレ asae コンターフロアーキラーああああ
だオープニンおあきら4 meee アニメムービー
アーム los パブ言います a bar
introduction to a 人
ディムービーだゴーん
を期したネームだろん
tms カーズ2スノータウン
ん
プロセス予定
sambar 5 e to do 日おめでとうございますありがとうございます
年金がポルシェをそう
さあ天作 name
パスワープアしーはふ mad プロストリームの xg スターレッドサーフィン
give a mature
由規橋本とお誕生日おめでとうございます
ケーキ台にありがとうございます
tnt これっていくらなのかな
ん
これ
金額ちょっとわかんないな塩 t て何
義則さんを対応はんじゃなかったかな
twitter で
1回観たんですけど
をとにかくありがとうございます大変
へ嬉しいです凄く嬉しいです
どんなケーキダイパ4枚 wi-fi rea ケーキショーウィンドファーム
ウェアーシーズメイキング
本命
[音楽]
ん moon
マッシュルームあ bosom イーフェイ soro the voodoo いい
それああああ
ism lebanon スターいまいち reinos 4 sbar アーカーブ
ano だあれファン4
来てくれたありがとうねー
それでちょうどは if you are in japanese me
お部屋でいやーこれからパワーキャスト wake up girls
face スター pn with great work das とぅ
そりゃあこれから吉野家義則さん
ああ
usd en 電球
誕生日おめでとうイングスワープ angew どぅアスペクト japanese
are forever forever is my pleasure ん
ns とペプシ面を誕生日おめでとう
ありがとうございます
ペンキあ
ターン
そう
住むマンショングリーン japanese メディアはん亭
プードゥル2 dao オーナー there are two
たマーレ diapers 使いネームああん
まあヨヌ金峰度ゲーム
裏ヒーリングキャンプ4 d ゲームバー&ページェント a 4 s 4 a
nanoo ピールアップファースター ab ソーラー see the
public
いるとぅもーる d アップまあプブ me 砂 darpa そこにメディアを使い
nba バーガー
陰でアフ
ブレイクダウン e 2 d アクションと japanese hpx bos
スーパー俳句オーディネールバーコーディングスーパーエロボディ
ますパワー cbr funny and see no story in
japanese
render japanese teacher 楠4-1
アメリアを
reb to do
voodoo
ぞんびりー
グードゥああ
ファビブルードゥウェイナイス
sox 件中はまあやなふぉあ
な
ウィリー pj
[音楽]
2位
altar ティーザーレス adenocarcinoma
を hd 商誕生日東京マインド出産見えます
renoise バージョン6 vsl ああ
ok mo
ペン9009 bs not to do にー
japanese forever str オーバーワーズ go into
asoda アーレスポーツ
鉄馬クリーム柄 nf 俳句
サビです
ソファニュー中バッグ表現俳句あ亭中火で増加 mars
okab ん by 連合さぁさぁ私は日本育ちのアメリカアメリカハーフですが
バイリンガールは良いことだけではありません
なぜなら両方の悪い分分が見える方です
もちろんいいこともありますがいいこともありますがとりあえず道元さん誕生日の
おめでとそうだよねいいことばっかりではないんですよね
僕はそういうなんだろうもともとその
ハーフじゃないからそのちっちゃい時から両方を使ってパっていうわけじゃないんです
けど私加工日本語を学んでいく
またアンディ
より多くの日本語の言葉を知っていると確かその自分の英語る英語力とか
どんどんどんどん落ちてしまうというか
いいことばっかりいいことばっかりではないんですよね
それは確か確かなことですね
ありがとうございます agb スター r スティングレーマーチ apc レア
んだ
pc 覚え
ウィズアフュー sa 純パーカー rader eusebe ちゅアウディ
continue do ニーズアドバイザーユーチューバー sri story
to do
プロスノー d サンハウス2
ビデオ230 ne to rear ベースサッカーウィンドファイザー米ドロ
グリーのブルースリーバーっ
lea senoo diondenbraber バーガーバーガーレッグ4 my
free time i s power
voodoo phone storage
jon r ずにしょべリアセットスーパーマーケットベリーアドスターバックス
インスリンビリアを売りアーバルーべリアを
ああっ
おや5 at orenge エフェクターフォースネイビー
to do 4 s ネイルアー
朗読 ios いい
薄いなぁもワーロン日朝
ダーツアワー cerebral ディンファッキン s true ドゥア
arms skype スタートライン n
ビンディアボセンスなぁはでアフィを b 4 a perdu ss ハーバー
ビューへサポート
[音楽]
パブ ara ara by 損傷ゲームいざ bust forever
お誕生日おめでとうございますイェイ ora ああ
ao セキュリティまあチャーハーラーやっ腹や払え
アプリ cn ペンキあファーウェイよ
ウォッシュ系面壁がなかなかいい感じじゃないか
そのもみあげ結構気に入ってるじゃない
ありがとうございます嬉しいです
refs 日本語上手 breast ハーブ acube 遊びのフューチャー
ハウス5ルーペ
re as a sore to do for
s 4 n box are you so des オーディション amazon
r パイプ王道ネイルああん
カタカナ集まりますね王だもの
[音楽]
カポ木主シャワーペンドラーケメン this card
マヨネーズ
3 b 6ファインバーグモンスターエッグ
社員 find ああ
カーズ処理ストーリーレポ japanese
いっ
ん
[音楽]
おっ
ぷっ
[音楽]
pop はぐっ
re sure です9 js でスウィングプレース wii 2わーん
4 a 8名本だけだけどんです
1 sansen
パティマース社 cad です
this バック0パーティユーザー s 4
あーディスポスローイング園舎サウザー
いやハーン
ファビバースト apr モンティバーチャルプルシェ
れてるってで happy birthday 分キューバー'煎茶
ディナー ng in cuba 立つ
うっ s 購入 ru n セキュア
アールグレイアウディ
雨分プリビスストリーム4の rb 2 prea ken o chin ファックス
dari ぷっ電球
see なぁ
するサプライズ
エヌエスコンチング l スマートなピュア
あーん
マヨネーズピータースバッパーぺチュアル the new シェア
プッシュあ ok anan 層は厚い
sa そんなムービー聞きストーリーサービス just plain フォーマル
バッグ4 me to do on
andem コース pou dou dou di んぐしょん
bd re マスターピース peres arme ボエーム are you
doing
pater ドネーション ways your tears アプリシェ
ああああん
貼っで
です
ストレスファイン endse メンバーとポスター
sexe アウェーで of work
ing 0 b 6
love 雨スター japanese for a reason e メール
ash プロん
プレッシャー x ぽいんですですずっ
voodoo arl
mariam ん
日1んだぷ s だけ
運営いましたけどと秋秋葉原
なんとか
明けミーティング me to do 5 rb スペシャル ebay borse
あペインティングのバーガー
僕10歳はプレーントゥ son of work
プレイしの浮世絵
あちゅれーしょんせんウィング carmona プロパティーズフィーズ
ing forever r はベイスターズああ
1酒
百合屋さん
ピス ahkah soo エスター
ana 10が gree
y ' bo njs コーン ir アーム rebase シストレプロファ
base heads ストーリージェンヌ osx スーパー semester 3
件と10ペア
比例ルアー
hero is benders 庭園
あヴぁいエロストリーム by スイング tome ずカウンター jpn
ゲーム instan デイリー使いスター
pou dou dou
prs anond ストーン
onerror ワーカープッシュノエル名
add キャディ who do you go スペシャル see the な
プレックス4
麻布オールドビーンズジャパン別 dj mike あいろん
ia
プー進むいいかってなんだろ親近感
i fear いいお
ia leto
pale to speak ill 編町6オーリス me by ああああ
i read me down for win skr deirdre ず
5校 jensen
にゃああ
oe アウディ cad ゾーン ad キャディファインアウディ q ゲーム
dap しぇんヒーター carry the who do my 犬
ディスプレイバー
l 名ワイプフィーチャーリングフォームすぅー
anone ceng サーブもうとぷもうツボもう頭房 xb しょんズ a 棟
けいおんスターファイターズを
ニャースーパースーパーブルーイング選ぼう
ras ワークスタッフフォーマー
asc us press to do フォーマーズアイハバページ esad
フェイス exr パー sr ああああ
1 semen 荒れず bernese barresi besar プレイらー
ん
5 f n see
exid want you バー
part 1 the
play ドンハバーガースーパー into 培土ウェイ
aware ケネフマイナータソムなおすすめ茶
日本でゴキブリ見た事がありますかありますよ
引越して6シッコしたばっかりの時に
新しいアパートに入ろうとしたら一気に3匹が出てきたんですよ
初めて見たのはその3右がバーって出てきた時なんですよねぇ
相当なんか
第1インチ省としてはけっまあ衝撃的でだったっていうかかなりなんか
えっ
これからの生活こんな感じって思ってちょっと
うん
凹みましたエコみました
ん
8グリーンストーンクロスチャーリーかーくを浴び米動画どうジェン
同源
先制できるっ
3匹みたらさーん逆引き言いますよねそうだよねー
いやそれまでな見たことなかったんですよね
それまで見たことがなくて
自分の
育ったところシアトルなんですけどシェア取る
は比較的涼しいんですよね涼しいからゴキブリうも一切ないよっぱ
こう呼ばれているところとか変わっただったらまあいるかもしれないんですけど
普通はいない普通に掃除しているところだったらいない
なんで見たことはそれまではなかったんだよね
だから自分の新しいアパートのドアを開けて3匹出てきた時はものすごくなんかこう
ショック受けたんっていうかこうえっ
憧れていた日本て来エイムこんな感じみたいな
彼もいないですがや彼も相当いましたよ
九州だったから結構なんかこうもう
東京のゴキブリとまた高レベルが違うっていうか
will do do 玄関ファー
エプロン常勤
全フリーズ2
夫婦 found this たんぽへいへい子
4ベース4 me with ディーラー網とフォース石窟
全部リザンバー words for answers
そう東京ラブストーリー by 概念道具 n high school of the
voodoo s 庭園
アーム
全部リズム相愛ファインダー付が in the 4ティング nippondanji
are you doing プロファ
nestor please go launcher 4 t see how do
do
ノックオールコンス ist キュッ desember blues for air
連投競争ん
カードバッグ mg ex インザフェイスは東京大阪名古屋犬でべくセリーズ横浜
anderen doren actor
スマーターんさーくーらーず別府 with ken o
あーん
終わるバイス
ガーディハーフヘアーライン根治揚場
nba ヘアーリンカーニャー
oe ハラー f 3 f 4 f 5ユーザー黎明 per i go to do
ong ヴァロワールピーポー4
ディスカー nf game for some 今 jsol ディファ
でかいのグループ parasa arenberg
desperate for a キーユーザー
voodoo んあうあーれ voodoo sa 4ストパーカー
4 you do
voodoo ジャストパティ
this マイペースの低下英語圏の人が日本語学習
したかったら関西弁覚えた方が楽な気がします
悪銭全色員というのは気がしますよっぴ奥様だったかなこれ
その方がネイティブに近づける気がします私の個人的な意見ですが道元さんどう思い
ますか
いやこれはわからんでもないけど
関西弁は
確か公営号の
ストレスアクセントに出る部分もあるけど
ガチで学ぼうと思ったらー
そういう高関西弁
が
きっちり学べる今日教材教科書とがなかなか無いんだよね
だから標準語だったらこれだけ
これほとんど全部へ
高低アクセントについての
教科書なんだけどもちろんこの中にも英語のやつもあるし
あっ
これとか使えばそのああああ苦戦との基本的なことは
学べるんだけど関西弁になったら
なかなかこう学ぼうと思っと思っても学べないっていうかーそれが学べる教材がない
から
こう頑張っても
どうにもならないっていうか
宝鋼
たしクソの似てる部分もあるけどガチで学ぼうと思ったら難しいからなかなかこうお
すすめできないというか
それが自分のスタンツ
少しでも努力すれば標準を
標準語のアクセントも結構
もうなんだろ身につくから
標準語を使った方がいいんじゃないかなって個人的に思います
関西に住むしかないそれもありありけどね
関西に住んで関西弁で行くからって決めたらそれでいいと思うんだけど
その関西から引っ越すかもしれないその可能性があるから関西
今関西に住んでるとしても
北
のオススメとしてはそれでも標準語を使った方がいい
結構そういう質問自分の生徒といいのかな
から受けるんだよね関西に
住んでるんだけどそれでもに好評人を学んだ方がいい
その答え僕がそれに対していつも聞いているのは長くそこに住むつもりですかそれだっ
たら関西弁で行
ツラに吊ら抜いた方がいいと思うんだけど
将来的に後東京とか別のところに引っ越す可能性が割れバーン
標準語で行ったほうがいいんじゃないかなって言っ
ポケサーん
大誕生日おめでとうございますあぁハードル foma フェイスチョン appear
to do in がー
ゲームファーム
いやぁあさん me フィリー6 give me forever ばいばーー
レイアウトウェアオリーブリーフィーリルバールツアー
lenore フォーム s 4 ing 弱自身風雲さあ releases 4
グラミー6 rr しょん e four s terreno リースリング
japanese for someone a 4 a doodle ます
モーション
大 japanese of time
voodoo ぴブーイ
6 ebe 4
雨ブルース japan raster version
ゲーム王者プリンスオブタイムアップ as ず
ベールディカーソンプロジ
日本を以外で何の言語に興味ありますか
競技位
今日興味
うーんあんまりない
ちょっと待ってイリヤさん異世界いや yes
るって出てる
他の言語に思う興味ないんだよ
パー戦記フレディヤードネーション
ありがとうございます
8ベース jester race ran japanese b cars アイ
アーム
bereit japanese idol ever in japanese
for x あんふぁん sa ファミール頭痛
キー p 神宮 japanese to do まーすとりーあ do do n
oe neba sperm speak english
baby japanese goods for a sore to do
bd を愛してます yj sambar マース for editing web
アイコン a seat to do on r うわぁ love is all m
バイカーパーティー new 損
ダーリングアドベンチャー yjs are you doing
ペンキ米マイスター s とぽい
[音楽]
prr 阿部アーマーファンミーティング externe ウイングロボ
re the pros 2 r 4 f tun ウェイ
者や催事スペース tre
ギバー unas にアカウンティングレールディア個人情報立明野ペーストの
re the board パスワード asan with 4 sod
youtube sp ボーダー
あ
1 d ブルースピークス ori ジョインツ usaf ミラー
stare ダウンロードするスピーカーバー
アワード japanese bastos 2スーパーカーを baby
walker
東京事変
椎名林檎
レッタれってああ
アルファドレス方法場所じゃピースパンツァー
[音楽]
あげ b 毎年チャー1君 ose さあやキュリーまいります
benq hoodia ドネーション apc
日本語の変化の速さについてどう思われますか
以前道元さんの動画で伝統的な日本語を使わず
外来語を使うことに
8因子を持ってなさそうだったので
ん
僕としては
その外来語あんま好きじゃないんだよね
その帰途へばもともとその単語が日本語になかったから
その単語を使うというのは全然アリだと思うんだよね
まあ例えばなんだろうこう
パンケーキとかもともとまあお好み焼きがあるんだけど
アメリカのパンケーキはそもそも日本になかったんだよね
だからそれを説明するためにパンケーキを使う
パンケーキという言葉を使うのは自然なことだと思うんだよね
でも
既にそういう意味を持っている単語だったらー
元の日本語でいいんじゃないって個人的に思います
まあ例えば何だろう
めっちゃあるんだけど飲んでも
ポンプ知見やは iphone 付
天体観測の4枚フェイス songs the masterpiece プッシュあ
まあ基本的にもともと同じような意味を
no
ある単語か日本語にあるのであればそれでいいんじゃないかなそれを使った方がいいん
じゃないかなと思うんだよねその平居子を好きじゃない一番の理由としては僕も個人的
な印象なんだけど
こう外来語を使うことによって自分を頭のいい人に
日光
外来棒を使ったら頭がいいと思われる
そういう雰囲気を醸し出してる人が多いん多いと思うんですよね
松といえば何だろう
わかんないんだけどいいすぐには重いかはないんだけど
祈祷会はあ
最近同館とか
僕もそう思いますとか
高
賛成ですとかそうじゃなくて
僕はアグリーしますとかそういうそう言ってる人がいるんだよね
日本人で
だからえっ賛成でいいんじゃないって思うんだよね
アグリーいって一行
まだそこまで高普及してないから比較的珍しい単語
なってるじゃんだから珍しい単語を使うことによって自分も珍しい存在おしゃれな
オシャレな存在だとこう主張しようとしている4人はようには僕見える
僕は損切る
まぁ勝手な思い込みかもしれないんだけど
意識高い系大学生とかビジネスマンとかかな
ああ
そそえび伝つ取ってるのとか
証拠でいいんじゃないん
ていた
その意見に強く賛成します
ありがとうございます
まああとまあ当然なことなんだけど
外来語を使えば使うほどその発音に
慣れ慣れてしまうじゃん
だからその外来語の発音に慣れてしまおうと
帰国しジョーとか子供のから子供の頃から英語を使っている人じゃない限りなかなかさ
の普通の英語の発音がそれがもっと難しくなるんじゃないかなと思うんだよねもう
ずっとアグリーとかアグリーとかええ ben とかって言っている
1パチだが急に m ベンツとかグリーとが言えるわけがないんじゃないかなと思う
よっぽど校
髪を普段からすごく発音を勉強しているになったらいいんだけど
ほとんどの日本人が多分いい語の発音が苦手
71番の理由としては
カタカナ英語に慣れているからだと思うんだよね
そう
じゃないかなあと思う
sos スタバソフィア sofia 4
sophia ソフィアウェディングソフィーローシュバーブ
開かれたきゅうりとネーションの先なガーン
プローム目ディナーべくとああ
this 本 us 4 se フェイザー
visa サンパークウェイ
fas 10 q 4 mon お誕生日おめでとうございまーすああいう brano
4 se moonraker eap シーター
2つは have you so all stars ん占有ウェイエンキュー do
前記 ipl アーム
エアーナビ柄ボア取るルっているアーサーん
ああああああああ
happy birthday パワー starting to do so me
to japanese ウィングジェント push to do s アーム
fof of the voodoo すべくと for new
ばラーン
f ハッピー to do in your
大変今起きました最初からだいぶライブ見たパターン
わっっ
まだまだやりますよ
今日はちょっと時間がありますので
それははず春流ストーン佐津温泉天宮そうまあ
[音楽]
dr japanese are your アイアールジャパングループちゃ
ああああああああや分科会ロワー
ウズベク系ファームスターを
iso with big ones b フレームカーボンバーベキュー the u
fas でな
う4 s 殿筋再度 adni zepp
プリ cl
stare to do
なんだっただったらまんだったかな
esr ジャパンブルードゥアかぱねぇ後の話は理解できるけど
実際日本人が良い子英語ぽくシャベルとしゃべるときカタカナ英語英語的な発音を使っ
てる人あんまりいない気がする
あー1それは人によるんじゃないかなと思うんだよ
もちろんその二弾カラー
英語をちゃんと勉強している人だったらー
ちゃんとお香を開けることができると思うんだけど
そうじゃない普通のそこらへんの学生とかそこまで英語に行こう
英語が好きじゃない人だったらいいことはないんじゃないかなと思う
まあ個人的な個人できない
印象印象じゃいけんだけど
日本語のわからない
結局判断するのは英語
ぼ鯉以後の人では
断裁ですか34です
村上春樹の神の子供を子供たちの絵
はにっ
は皆
踊る
踊る踊る
が読んだことあるないですぼく村上春樹好きじゃない
no
あろうマイキーあ村上春アーティーズウイングライド by ディストームアイキャン
ras by ringstars アマチュアファームラパ3流
[音楽]
none xtender アーレ also to do
4 mon oct # p ゾーン
new tube oo
face on プッシュアバックスマートライダー ori コンチング
フィールダー角度 japanese さん
同い年だった a そうそうなの
さあ平成名受講
パーサーエンキュートン増備でおめでとう
ウォッチャー love miy フェスメイキン方メールラブオーリー
ええっ
form to do in form
with ぬ
with the finder 複数エクステンダー付
系好きなポケモンとか言いますか
え
ピカチュウ
ポケモンそこまで好きじゃないんだよねこれ
はうれしいオーリーの& d 4 adf
あボックスレコメンデーションず黒子 generation tour
4 re driving
粟辻ユーツたち by 金原ひとみ
noa d like うーん
this superb せくちー9倍村上龍
悦バーを号ヘイズ to do ナインティナイン
ああああああ n
das terren voodoo 4にアワーある総務に term for
wii なブログ
par ストーンスポルディングトーマス多く自分の動画の中で言っ受けます
july 1st perseus a nap to do
プリジェッターな民族を集め
天久しょりー
俺マイカー nb 50 r スティファイティング
pou dou dou
ブーム4 nars だけウィンドペアーん r ペルー
vol 44 nanban
4 step 4向こうちゃーん
わお
犬大津バス ls ファイバー
へつなぐダブモチーフウェインバーグシーエスピーポージャパンディファイ cars
rr 4 s bar red army 6帖リポーズ japan
rap ボーダーれ
guard pro 4プレイ13分
for your dare キャン4エフェクター
あーん日本の月収がアメリカやヨーロッパと比べて低すぎる件についてどう思いますか
そうだねそれは確かあそうだと思います
あの
普段普段から僕あっちゃん
中田敦彦の youtube 大学見てるんだけど
彼が最近アップした a
やすやすい日本
っていう本を紹介したんだよねでその方の中で
その日本の月収が
以下に聞く以下っていうのをよく膏貼っ
説明してくれたんだけど
パスかにこれでは低すぎるなって思ってたんだよね
でも月収が低いのはなんだろその
いろんな原因があってそうなってるんだよね
んだからっ
経済的に今あんまり成長してないからこそ
さっき言ったように収入を
ガーがある外国人が日本に来た方が
経済が回って
まあ教育の質とかが上がってそれによってすべて
まあいいことがあるんじゃないかなと思うんだよね
だから会社だけが悪いとかそういうわけでもないと思うんですよね
会社がまあお金がそこまでないから
低いんじゃないかなーっていいこともあるんじゃないかな
すまーそう思うんですもちろん良くない会社も
当然あるのはありますけど
nubar 漁場区長やアイディアや膝
pseg ea 6 a so [ __ ] re not to do アヴリーン
そうポリー information you do for んさーむーいー遭遇
ルアーインター
あーや野草がやや
drum エッグ8サービスジャパン by
プレーティングダウン purely ユーザーリー
ターキーのバッティングさあ昨日根本 as 複利の力とかそういう濃厚徹底的に
細かく丁寧に説明できることが
すごく大事だと思うんだよね
日本
風習
風習だよいいのかな知るかよなかなか読めなくなって
日本週間変えるのが家
西難しい部分がある気がします
水溶性質問があります私は日本語能力試験1級合格を目指していますが漢字が苦手です
何か感じを学ぶコツがありますか
うーん
僕としては
その
一番いいんじゃないかなと思うのは
感じだったらそうだよね
暗記と
その感じが何度も出てくる
メディアを使った方がいいと思う
だから僕がよくやるのは例えば
さっき言ったようにあっちゃんって言う
youtube ユーチューバーの動画を見るんだけど
その動画いろんなとピコー彼が紹介してるんだけど
その1回きりじゃなくて一同
みた動画を何度もマンでも見るんだよね
何度も見ることによってその動画に出てくるパン5
知らない単語
を知らないうちに覚え覚えていくんだね
で感じもそうなんだよね
を競え
日本はルールを変えるのはへ
嫌がりすぎなのでは
やり過ぎなので一応日本はルールを変えるの
嫌がりすぎなので
うん
もうそういう人もたくさんいますねー
そうだねまあ難しいとこ
でも手ではあると思うんだよね
わーワンテンキーグレーマーチ media
ドネーションな pc デー
なーんて側もしたければ
収入は別にそこまで気にしないけど職場のストレス満載な雰囲気と環境は本当に改善し
なきゃいけないと思います
そうだな僕もそう思います
そうすることによって
その
社員たちもより結果がより良い結果
出せるんじゃないかなと思うんだよね
だから正社員たちをよりもっとこうもっと大切にすることによって
会社の利益も上がるんじゃないかな
そうなるといいけど
her ear to do
とぅ baby hard by how サーズ4なぁマーシュハウ
ん
rx peres reorder are you doing キャンビー座
田 unb goodbye term
tree ハーディ10歳ですごい21 den o ore de ハウスジャパン
ああああ6
ゲームんですはボディーて葵西
ぶー by スターゲイト r オーナーズでロープストライボス今日セビカー
pri ボス系 someone i ライン
ベニーキャンセルダウンローザペインホップ afm スポンサージア
nested の療養はカーマインディズニーちゃ
頃イカー
本社はって company of love バーバリー現場ベース
fortigate td 4 gamer か b surfer
アヌ
浜辺
retry 伏せオンリー本
アズポーズ2
voodoo masks ベイリーフピーボ to do ボビーペルー
bearbear bearer p ソープ pou dou dou
ウェアー
強い place to the mix アイピースプッシュ
あーん
ny クイーンピースワーワー kei to render smiling ステム
ios 理由
id my first to
ウォーカーれカービー所
フォース2
reloop #ロスタイムエッグ
スティック coaster racer
ダース買うファンカーン
気にティーチャー素バタープランス英書 now お前はもう死んでいる
pusan 名ボーイズを客層
お前
フォアお前はもうねもうはずダンスてポンディもうお前はもう
死んでいる
死んでいる oso 祖父はいつは死んでいる
ns な
おひらんず実は死んでいるずお前はもう死んでいる
rba web 西武 as コーン
プリ can
つい
青いさあ日は彼はメリディアンか revo お誕生日おめでとう
道元さん
ありがとうございます嬉しいです
ok オッシーはいどようびぽいてああ
rb xl four s farm masanori カーブ ane ソーラー
to do グレーひやー
oek pas クリープ astm a seat to do for エスケープ
スマートパスバーレルわー
一蔵尊チャーや you do if
webike 臨時フィギュア
俺と with the weather in
xor deemo コンテンツ em 3 star 犬
ウィル g ex ターポン youtube
フェ bar in japanese japanese only to do
for エッツ本良い歯ビナードぴーぽん sns ペース
会津5
isan ウィンフィールドネーションの pj
そうアメリカそれ以降52
聞いビーチターン with a view to do this derb
cars 母のワイプ
と何度高
赤ちゃうダブルベリースモールワールド1000st
姫 tx arase 新曽 inoreader aso render
aspera グレーティング
ああっ
雨 s world bui バーガー
ちょっと待ってねー
[音楽]
お外へはそういう船
ああっ
フォースいい saben バーミーズファインダーん
を編みん
first base 王 f wing ベース as 5 s が
[ __ ]1 people don t youtube just one 週2回
部数村 youtube リールディスク nu do スパーン
なんだ
spst no
andere 寒い to do スパー tend to
エッグバーガーインストアマーケティングあいむそぅりーなーバーイ
パッソ x levis 4 ay るー
nan ディスクリプター sos dba インポートティミーエンサー oo
web enda マーカー部 a sore to do 6
discord work with サムワンライクマインドする speak
数あみんです
rrp reale spectral force ordered to do
the first out みん
[音楽]
forever tx ref 4 ae アウディクーラー shure m all
4 at クリーナー場所分
フェビアン付
西アウェイ4 with this drama 10寸
あ
r en us リー pou dou dou
いう縁 name ポステックサーフ
アーサー jr線カルジェルペアーん
dero ば母アケミラリー麻布オーリーデー
ren 4
nso ず名 br ベッドポピーるー
ぶれーキンズラーケミーに
ファイルスエー recomend ユーイング4 s japanese
english
my job to feel my arm 浴びルームウォーカーブルードゥ
ゾーン
アーム
na 原理カジュアルスクープ peiper down to do the
author ん
マイルーム star in for a パーリングああ
おめでとうございます
永平寺そうだなこれ誰の
あ17.9ワゴン中古ディスプレイディ
q sfu none グレービーソース4羽 in japanese d 0 ta
ro con japanese english tips あーけ
赤で宮
4倍 in japanese で次郎と xbox
俺
r 4ds ng なああああああヘッドベストオプション is to do in
japan
s 2
ユーザーサービス xk 杏子あ僕といいはアクションファー
ウィンドゥサムピングいーくん by oh my マーグ
で rover ローバー一服そんなんけんど aed スパイ
あのーザビスハフ
yaso creen メーカーは伊豆ファーファ
ああああん
r ポーチ a pas 竜の卵キンダー cereus ジュトゥ
us by wmg フェンダーずコンピューターなどスケープ ou 相応
nds 2 nds パブ良いシステム
縦横ドブスワンダーウーマンず
ran germano
オーストラリアカラー
お誕生日おめでとうベクターやんです
台風者と呼べるぐらい
台風車でいいのかなこれ何て読むんだったっけ
ちょっと待って
これ
大変わかんないんだけど a ちなみに e 2チャーシティスパーク s パワー
キャスに出ますか
いつも助っ人を見て僕ショーします最後に道元さんのおかげで中キングを始めて結局
工事になりました
すごいなおめでとうございます同じ34歳のディスコールで日本語を教えている家庭
教師より
お疲れ様この間の早口言葉すみませんでした
いやいや
他に書くありがとうございますあーん
4ホップ avion いいファーシリーズとユーザー名ボディバックスイング
スコーンであろうヴェルディ
バーン
いや
ペン9 do you author h 北京北京
ras alen geere gba are as a
嘘の豚ジョウビ with bread in japanese 育つ5分
ストリームスコータイ風邪
asp 使うで誕生日スペイン5 dvd のちゃーん
4 saines ターフィーもキーボードペン型バーチ
リース treno グッチウメニーインジャージーズ notes
セキュリティもアノードリポート day 3
i had to hard wear with teen interbase
ブログライターオーナー with ジェクティ me to do for スター
フィギュアーツ仮面 but by min
あーお誕生日おめでとういつも見てます
来月日本に引っ越します五門堂元さんと同じくらい話せたら
なぁと思います思ってます
かも頑張ってください
ファンジャパン happy to be ああああ
アーカイブを残しますかここは
午前6時ですのではい残します
too easy arus 4 ar 2 do vale
voodoo スターファイルいいフォームダウン
あーん
はーいで生
道元さん you are
郵送クォースマークエッグはっぴープレイ air
ありがとうございます電球安
takuya さん質問を多くの日本人が雰囲気を
雰囲気ということを道元さんはどう思いどう思っていますか
特定は難しいんだ
[音楽]
日本語どこれは
ねえぞ is ば桜といって
これを発音するときはこの言葉の中で発音するときは
したがどこにもつかないんですよねでそれによって
いいと同じようにどこにもついてないんだけど
だからこそその区別がまくなっつかなくなった
つかなくなってそれによってこの発音になったんじゃないかなと思うんですよね
難しいところだけどなぁ
きっと
やそりー
発音って言う
だよね発音じゃなくて発音
ノート
それが
母音の前に来ると
ビーダーコンビだコーンでいいんだっけびたコーン
ビラク
おっ
鼻を抜けるボーイになるんだよねそれによってタブー
[音楽]
ピンキーなったんじゃないかなあと思う
あ
voodoo arso ウーファーレザー
スキー済みんああ
big 3 ss 5 price in カー for air
rebase sed 管理サービスはなんていうんだっけ
b 美蛇行んじゃねーよね美学を間違えだっ
なんだったかなぁ
鼻を抜けるボーイん
のんきの頃
これかもしれないちょっと待っ
美貌イン reborn うーんこれたぶんこれだと思う
うーん
これだから
雰囲気なっちゃっぱんじゃないかなあと思う
日蛇行の違うピザ今は実は違います
いや日凧
ちょっと待って
や日だコーンというのは
別の別のやつです日だこわ
ガーとか
がじゃなくてがになることを
示してるんだよね
表している
美貌員はその鼻を抜ける暴飲
なんだけど日た今は花ぬ鼻を抜けるボーイんじゃなくて
可能抜ける
破裂音
ガッとか
躁躁躁躁躁日だ今はが
とかですですね
いや日だ本はがギグ受け子とか
日本人より詳しくて薄毛えいええやこういうのを普段から教えてるからこう
当然
まあそうしは知識があります
少しますん
ハービー adabas dupa 兄 bn ああ
re an r 2ドゥユー by t pudu を
bno つを ten
あーん
1900だあ
[音楽]
病気 ni ベンツチャーリーのは感じハーボー rs ways 音読み nop
プランテーション ender ender チャーリーのプランテーションベイ
ジョン rione 分丈なボス
[音楽]
バラ
prendere エディションツアー
voodoo best story japanese
ミイラ mr チャー g を in japanese noo 粗粒感じ
word でん今寺院 en
アーキーワードベイマークっ
バビディ forward to do in a 4
インディビジョンカー二走歴ビューエスペロリーム apn ドラマー来て感じ4し
最高
ワールドへ向かう g 4ファイア6
高
february mi ペーニャ
あー何歳ですか道元さんへ34歳です
エロゲー枠数うさ
パウダーで tb カープボール esperde astronomer スピード
パワー連符 ome ビーンズ japanese ストーリー4 ar ハッピー
アワー wii は言う
re you doing ココローズ
ブログラム
余計
電気深めねー
払うミックス are you ok
ピアノハーバード+とパパ
日本で個人へ
事業主ん事業主
っていうんだったっけこれちょっとばっかなん
フリー版つになるのは難しいと思いますか
いや難しくないと思いますスキルがあれば
俺バイシーハプニング霊夢ディ japanese m エディション
noresore er 4 n one いうポイント p to do you
were you ルームあ
words japanese movie をのりピー2
ビッグヴィジョンワーズ japanese army
ムービーをのりピー
were you do n
meander 9ヒューザー図2
[音楽]
物品 r 22 r スピース all up your face p コンサー
ケアー
星3スピークス u 2
僕を
フェミスピークセキュピンキーポスター p ねハーフアピ別邸
どう玄天宮
韓国から見て今の誕生日骨等
そしていつも良い動画ありがとうございますありがとうこちらこそあるありがとう
ございますすごく嬉しいです
ice wear
ほんとしぐらい韓国に住んで進んでました
まさにあの
タウンナムスタイルが流行ってた時
その時に観覧に住んでました
ん
25ウィザー perdere nu do
render ペン q 4エギブルードゥ4
ハピバースデー soi サウンド led カー n びゅーてぃーちゃー kno
フェンス oder スポンッ
exe
みゃお restores 寒いますゼロ者数0件
t have a donate 混戦 bernese ず phone the
大きいはスティックザーザーハートパヴェコントローラーないでー
rc never be youtube だーらー駅ドア
ならバイク中田敦彦ヒール電影少女 nestrobe ブログだうッッ
さあ rebre japanese german
nas センサー
ティックカバー sr マイン雪隠所へ apoon
バリキュア were you do my father is meant to
be a good アーマー村
ta ハビビルディングとピンズ公園ケアー
カーリン japanese rebase wb ユース tf ムービー
njt 人エディション to japanese words ザ
g 浴びるヒューバー
上限3ds ファイアーユーク nud スピーク0 ni どんずまりグアム
other
sonocore cpac emr careme hearty クイーンズ
forever れ premage アウディスプリークイーン
さ
アンバーや異論スピーカー兄クリーンセンターまぐれアーマー
どんなパスとウェバーしまい enodeb c with ball mas
days
4パブいいなぁあ
2 mature ファイル a b c 250
メールしぬわああ
遅くなりましたが雰囲気は感じをちゃんといいよま読まないで覚えている人を覚えて
いる人が間違って話してるだけでしょうね
今日が誕生日なのですかおめでとうございますおめでとうございます
それもあると思うけど
それプラス
その
美貌イン
ガー単語の真ん中に入っていることも原因の一つの一つだと思うんですよ
個人的にそう思ってるんですけど
両方あるんじゃないかな多分
でまぁなんでかっていうと
その間人をちゃんと読まないで覚えている人が間違って話してるだけでしょうね
だったらなんでそもそもそうなってた
もともとなんかの原因があってそれになってそれになった後でそれを聞いてああ
この単語の発音がこれだと思いこんでいる人たちが出てきたっていうことだと思う
ですけどだったら最初にそれに最初その二
医院
その正しいハポンじゃなくて今の発音になっている別の原因があったっていうことじゃ
ないかなと思う
わかんないけど
あーん
ミカヅハヴィヴァルディファムホはいいセキュア pc apoon favor
image apc ターズヴァーダーフリーなチーズ
もう
音だと定員とかっぽい人いますね
うん
だからその
発音日本語の
発もんじゃなくて発音
が原因じゃないかなと思う
aa by スターリン jp 洗濯船ファッションストーリー uso r あーむ
e so with mature japanese スパスポーツ王
ディンガーの frp モード interseason see a movie
oreno バーガー
日家族20だ ndc ん to do japanese grammar 客
スパークオーディション to do me
ウォーカーファッカーズアストン actor
あ
でぬ
ur nomore bert jesse ネーターパクウォンスンプレイング
ゾーン
derp モード22
ああああん
ハピ部停波大村 howdy story 4
あで中ハブフランジ
やす愛
あでおにぎりフロンコンビニ
エンドポイントプレイスプーンコンビニ普段ポテトたかとかあんま食べないんだけど
今日は特別にに3ヶ月ぶりに
統制と食べました
体育
体育を
体育と呼んだりー読んだり
全員をメイン
と発音することがよくあることがよくあるように厳密に発音を
気にしないせシチュエーションが多くて
うんキハ
ふっじゃない
ふうたのね
が広まったって感じじゃないかな
あ
それだと思うだからそれと同じようにもともとその
んが
ゲーン員であって
それでその間違った発音が広まったってことなんじゃないかなと思う
ああああいう evs
[音楽]
そう考えたらちゃんと発音していない単語多いなぁ
うんナイス昼ご飯
そうだな
久久しぶりに食べたら美味しかったなぁ
お子様は何語でへ育って育てていますか
家の中で基本的に英語を使って外では基本的な外というのは学校とか
んシッターさん雇ってるんだけどその人とか学校では基本的に日本語
いや子供の言語力って本当にすごいと思うんだよね
学校4人に入るまではほとんど日本語できなかったんだけど
幼稚園に入ったらもう一気に日本語でてきて出るようになって今では今さん
もうちょっとしたら4歳になるんだけど双子いるんだけど
いやはもー
すごいよ本当に子供の言語力言語力っていうかその
銀5
身につ
が身につく
身につける力なんていいのかな
言語力でいいのかがわからないます
ああいうウィアーチェックすチェッカーズ母燕京バージョン pcp やー
voodoo sr 4 s ear forever れスピード pou dou
dou
4 n one to do bap
ヴィッカーズディープ nodu do ゲームオーバー appear to do
to
パーム eba メンバー bones
日 cars ザラインをでコンセント4位ザページェント
derb to do n ワードメイビーバイク
中破 pso 23 ost 雨エブリデイ
のマロはインドだプロデュア
ザロビー町ぺディフュー japanese apn
ディフューザースペインとオールドタイムウォッチん b 2バース
日 cars 上げ28桁ピール dm 4 mmap ニャー
様なくパシ研かマネー
言語学習能力それかもしれないな
習得能力分それ両方療法
とにかく子供はすごいってことなんですん
子どもってすごいなと思っ
バイリンガルに育つと
可能性が広がりますねうん
畳信じてます
oka
とウィンチお笑いデビュー se アバターん
わかんないなオレは動画の中だったらいいんだけど実際に人の前に出て何かをすると
緊張して
できなくなっちゃうそういうタイプだから
難しいかもうわーめっちゃやばターンなあー
[音楽]
pornstar japanese に apuri フィックスロープオーナー
can speak easy star live action movie いい
アドバイスウォッチもうライブアクションスタームービーズ
ダーツとビールかぁああああバス wedding itil ウェイ
亜美 nande のペイン3バッグ剛角2 ostara バー2
ムー japanese pop ミュニケーション
でん
sportus 5アクションパワーウィザーズ to do the n
jia シンボルずティック4 through life enman さんず
4 vivalo グリーン8 mo no も japanese ブルーライブ
アクションスター
by enemi アクション easee アイコン松明
no te アウディ to know モーター今 time forever りん
japanese すっ
アイン pom さんピンキーあーげーのーとん the voodoo four 4
madeinjapan アーカム面2波 perse
エアのファブ3つアワード ns ファーファ
ディメス3 p に who are you away サウザー
道元ですよろしくお願いしますアニメの日本語は
たまにおかしいえっとこあるよね
間に目もそうだし
ドラマとかもそうだし
普通の日本人のさベッテル日本語もそうなんだけどアニメは比較的
変な日本語っていうよりもその設定が現実とは完全に行こうかけ離れているから
高
立体起動掃除そっそじとか
村その単語が日常生活の中で出てくる可能性をゼロじゃんそもそも
だから
その日本語がおかしいというよりも現実にプラ得ない日本語
現実味回せない日本語が
まあにアニメによるに目によるんだけど
まあとにかく
現実に近い方が日本語の学習にいいんじゃないかなと思う
andere ランサーカバー bera denn
衛兵道具 none の配布パターインチアップ通信
進撃の巨人あ約3 have seen リィエンダー進撃の巨人
rer web セキュリティプラス re 杏子あー
to do for me
道元さん進撃の巨人では誰が好きですか
リブアイリバ絵やもかっこいいけど
ライナーが一番好き好きな治れば
そのキャラクターがー
複雑で行
リアルっていうか
そのなんだろう
罪悪感を
持っている感じがすごく伝わってくる
それがすごく好き
何だろうエレン
最後まで読んでないからわからんけどもエレンとか誰だったかな
が b と加工
どっちかって言えばシンプルじゃないけどとにかく敵を倒すみたいなそういうキャラ
キャラじゃん
特にが日はああっマートでくるかも変わるかもしれないけどそういう意味でまあ結構
早い段階で今自分の家
ていることってだろうし楽しいのかなーって
まあそう思い始めて性格が壊れたら位になって面白い人間に近いなあって本当に思って
たんだよねもちろんそのエレンが実際にマーレに行ってそのライナーと話しているとき
はああ lm をそういう
夢もあるんだと思ってたんだけどどっちかって言えば
まあよりライナーの方が高
何だろう自分の
背負っている罪の
おこうなんて言ったらいいのかなぁ
とにかくリアルだと思う彼はすんごく
れている
9月のブルードゥポゥ中もベーコンず from you nu do スティ
スポーンキャスああ
ホッピーりーわんさぁゲームマイバッグ can order
エンディング今 dre 東京ベイベー
70年代のアニメを見たことある長い70年代は食べないな
アキラはあるけどそれは1988年だったかな
ライナーが一番
人間臭さがありありますありますね
あ
ライナーは真の主人公かも
本当にそう思ってる俺は
内心で葛藤している間ジグですねうんそれ大好き
ライナーのことを話しているときの目の科学輝きすごい
おやもう本当に
諫山先生
って良かったかな彼を本当にすごいと思うんだよね
原作者もライナーすきっ
遠いですもんね草草草草草草
いやだから
ダイナを本当に
藤蔵人物としては
素晴らしいどうも
道元さんはもはや日本で育ったんじゃない
そうだったんじゃないかと思っちゃう
そこまでじゃないと思うけど
言われてみればライナーは一番リアルティーに近いですね
うーん
話題なぁ本当に
登場人物として面白いなぁ
なんでこうここまで情熱的になるん
俺がね情熱的になるかというと
自分も
自分で言うのはあれなんだけど自分も物書きとして
あーちょっと待ってね
そういうのを気にするものすごくなんかこう
そういうことを考えながら考えながら見るから
あ
ここがうまい違ってソース国幸
思っていうか
心の底からそういうのを
ちょっと待ってねー
スマートライフ新座ブレンダーグレーくああ
売ってるっていう
use
naruto 大好き道元さんなるとも好きだけど
maruto
より進撃の巨人を好きだな
進撃の巨人より
より
モンスターが一番好きあーば弱い funny the voodoo o
[音楽]
なんか言ってたな
を duty to japanese スペイド所 is this point
アップスいいなぁ所 is japanese ウェーブ枚
aqua first blog
ふーん
月生
apo japanese
ウェインルーニーのスピーカー付
でん
パンへいへい s watcher 普通
おめでとうものすごく可愛い
er 4ストリーム x n 5 at 1名
様バリーヘアー sr 伊豆チャー
smad ハッピー phew ウェイター
パー現世のニューハウス sterben
voodoo ワーム
this ちん番目を画廊
を作るストリームバッグ
iora droom ダブ
クリーフ web 映画はねそう
脱スプライスプリーンバーけなーず
ピンクスター by dre pcdj うーん same as ジョイナー
刷毛 imos 10cm ずえっつ
you guys まあ ip アドベリーハード坊ラバー
いやー返球ヘアー sd スプリームビーズん
b new
まだバク転できますか出来ません今
ずっとまだ勉強しないと罪悪感を感じますか本444
ダウンですか
本で読んだんです
本で読んなんですよ
どういうこと
あ
は座薬か終わりますね勉強していないと
コメント読んで頂きありがとうございますいやど jet チーズキャリイスピーポー
コースターセラーが感じ politics
お兄ちゃんミックスなクソ教えろ
ん
ん girls on s
sr システムの音 greeeen ジャック
asai フォローアップ2グループ youtube egami 号プラーン
ipn perder ヘルパー bing ウェブ os が
iphone アプローズ up you do
ユーザ b 層ピムファイフ
[音楽]
行くパーラービーズ birds ファイアーモーターキャンプせる forever
youtube demande オーバーウィッグ
ベーコンず wiki you can have もうスティックスペイン
スキャバーズセレブのグローブ
9食べる天日ボーディングノールせ
ブーブー render roop ブーイングスパー les parapluies
オープンスムーズ名計4ん
destination ずベルセプロジェクスペイ
we have no スポーティーレスラーの瓶 search of ちゃ
ガールズゲーム4すせそ web for air
旗セグバイ
youtube as キャバベース asaden オールキャムあ
グラミューズ nobasu stripper ローズ xx you do
rf 名 name pretty cure ゲイ5 d 2倍んるースタッフ
キースのポイン noris ペンツールバー平凡 ai af on the
バーガー
ん
ヴィッカーズ bb ちゃーらーサウザーエロー秋葉バッグ御膳いい jester
ファイバー nd 分通路
フォロアーウィーピーポー4
ウンジョングラフィティサウダージ pers birds サウンド
pandapia グリーンバッグゲームあ
ist ブルーやりー2サッカーのファイルドローマイクロフォン4村とないかなぁ
for you ず
その駅 b スパーダーファイルボックスの前ぐ
n マイク
you do for a gps キャブオールユーザー名254 s words
ユニー ndas トラック4 aros パイファイルローズん to
youtube セラピーぐ news pease
anone アップ
5ウォン
ダートラ adreno my youtube プラン stars were to
r バーグ d 9 mn
英語を勉強中なんですが日本をも英語も花話してくれる
おかげでいい勉強になっていますよかったです
と
で g
女 g た枠3を払う
腐ってよよ産むのかなこういう文脈で
ん
カタカナ漢字どれがひらがなカタカナ漢字どれが一番嫌いですか
方がなカタカナが一番書きにくい書きにくいというか
美しい母でカタカナを書くのが書くのはすっごく難しいと思う
感じだったら
ごまかせるんだけどカタカナはシンプルだから
なんかこう
これとかシンプルであるゆえに難しい
そのヘタクソ
下手なのがすぐにばれちゃうというか
ごまかせない
うん
日本語と英語以外に塩しゃべれる件へ外国語はありますか
ありません
スペイン語高校時代
勉強してたんですけど今は便へもう全く出てこない
カタカナが難しいのはすんごくわかるんだよね
日本人だったら多分みんなそう思ってるんじゃないかな
バランスが難しいですね
本グルも綺麗な書き方が分からないん
ところで
ハリウッド映画の吹き替えの動画めっちゃ面白かったですよかったです
これ結構頑張って作っ
作りましたん
なので嬉しいですカタカナを書くとき
書くときずっとロボットぽい書き方のほうがいいでしょう
そうかもしれないひらがな者以外と難しい枚柄もめっちゃくちゃ難しい
俺って大学時代さっきも言ってたんだけど行ったんだけど
大学時代は比較的感じもひらがなも
時に感じ
綺麗な方だったと思うんだけど
どういくら頑張っても頑張っても
寛永カタカナは綺麗にならなかっ
自分が見てもすぐ解った解ってたというかこれは下手くそだなって行
いくら何回か行ってもらっこれだめだなーってずっと思ってたん
エットっ
素晴らしい誕生日になりますようにどう言及ある
つまり押すというのが理由てからも
お誕生日おめでとうフォームメーラーキンファ nb 横浜フェン9 ster 合う
浴び横浜横浜ず
carver 今フェーブ3 japan だろうウェビナーを別府
ターンうえうえんでいいのかな
お誕生日おめでとうございますありがとうございますねキーワードファッション apc
客観的に見て日本語と英語で学ぶない7インド
これなインドでよかったっけ
まあ
南院動画違いがあると思いますかうん難しいところだなあこれは英語と日本語てこう
根本的に違うから
比較するの結構難しいと思うんだよね
なくこう英語の発音のの方が
難しいんじゃないかなって個人的に思うけど
日本語の書き方スマソの感じとかの方が難しい
でもそれだけだったらどっちが難しいかって言えないじゃん
だから後総合的に考えたらどっちもめっちゃ難しいという結論
は同時通訳ってどうやったらできるようになると思いますか
a
減収しかないんじゃないかなぁ
日本語が下手です
ウェスト aph axis m 4お誕生日おめでとうございます
お願いされることがイペ嫡孫
お誕生日
おめでとうございます
ウェルが視聴者に入って草
これ誰だろう
v 2バー b
中はこれだ
この人
秋谷 pou dou dou
あーん
北九号が
どの言語に似ている似てるか学ぶ
難しさって変わりません変わりますよね
例えば日本語だと英語より中国語に似てるから
日本人にとって中国語の方が学びやすかったりしますねそうだね
そうですね
おやす
アップスプリング
wais で道具 b 2バーバター
まだまだだな日本人はお誕生日おめでとう
よりもはっぴーばーすてって言いますねそれ大嫌い
日本語をつかいましょうよ韓国語
韓国語と日本語が一番似てるから
インテルから文法がすごくに似てるってよく聞きますね
韓国韓国語韓国語
簡単でも韓国語の発音は
めっちゃ難しい
らし
黒板を韓国風
高校9番らしい
そうなんだ何歳ですか34歳です
はジェスサブスクライブをサブスクリプション
えっどういうこと
最近はハピバ見るハピバとか止めて欲しいなぁ
鍛造秒までと
って言わない
今日はニュー reduced to japanese pets ペインクリ
fun surf パー4 boso フォロワー wii ありがとうございました
良かったです
dao hdr as is taster あ
#8 b ルアー
s 003 n オープンいいねぇんですかうんで r べ
ああああああ
アミーボディバッグシーンスタースプーン
winner 東京ザックリーズインふっ dexee render スペインさあ
the big bass pod わぁスターミーガールズを寄付
nap get back シーンやイン別府ヴィッカーズボウラームーヴブルースあ
東京に住んでいる外国人から飛ん増備おめでとうございます日本語大学で勉強したとき
カタカナとひらがなカタカナひらがなと漢字と同じように綺麗に書くコツがあると
教わった
いやきれいに書く
選手以外へ
綺麗に書くコツないんじゃないかな
今何アニメを見ている
アニメは進撃の巨人を繰り返して今見てます
めっちゃ勉強になるからなんかめっちゃ難しい単語いっぱいてるからね
3 find me everything ras al エンダー
n u sen
あ
進撃の巨人
ではし総務にハード words
名前の魔法そ見れて嬉しい
よかったです
軍事的なアニメですごく難しい単語出てくるよね
ねっちゃ出てきますねいやーもうなんだったかな
そのビリーさんだったかなビリーと
曲田体調がー
車じゃないけど
そういう艦隊とかそうだぬ
はリス誕生日バースデー
2人が2人がこう話し当てる場面が特に難しい
そうこのその部分を何度も何度も最近見てます
進撃の巨人で難しい言葉って例えば
なーん
7たエピと ever
なんだったかなその日リーガー
あえていっ
スピーチをする
だよねそれによってその敵の正体を行
炙りダスッ
そういう計画を立ててるんだよねその
そういうことをまが叩いちょっと一緒に話してて
こういうセリフあったと思うんでね
どうなとなって立っえちょっと待って
狙われるとしたらやはりやはり演説の最中でしょうか
うん
なんだからダウン件できませんがその可能性としてはそれが一番高い
でなんかこう
その
[音楽]
なんだったかなあその自分以外のマーレイの軍事の人たちを行動殺すかそういう花そう
いう会話をしてるんだけどその中で
その偉い人たちが
を一気に死なないように
防衛策
として習わしまあなんて言ったっけ
バシャバシャ追う使おう様々な8人
は場所を使おう
防衛策があるなかなか思い出せないんだけど
[音楽]
ネタバレはカーン
でもそのなんだろ習わしとか
8人とかなんだろうこう
[音楽]
その場面で他に何があったっけ
結構とにかく難しい単語いっぱいでます
だから水ですごく勉強になる
ビリーは政治家らしい話し方してますものね
そうだね
so many ways なぁシーンルージュセグウェイ dvd はーるー
しかもそのなんか高レベルの高いユーモア
もう
特にへ
マカと体調が使うからそこらへんもめっちゃ勉強になる
そのなんか
ヘリオス helios なったっけ
周りの英雄の像があって
れビリーはそれについてやもまさに
マーレの魂みたいなことを言うんだけどそれに対してやまたとエッ
[音楽]
今戸ドアせ下へ
マガト体調がー
クードまさにそうだな空洞ですしとかって言って冗談で返してるんだけどそこら辺とか
もう難しい
道元さんは英語をしゃべっている時に日本語の単語発音してもピッチャーアクセントも
完璧な貴重な
方ですいやー完璧じゃないじゃないんだけどね
私の日本を下手ですがユーモールでみー道元さんのチャンネル大好きよほっダメ前
スティングレーマーチアームファビー
もし新規の巨人などといったアニメで勉強したり挑戦したりしないと日本語の能力は
達せ
上達していけないん
いけないだろうと思います
とにかくその難しい
日本語
普段からこう
聞いていないとダメだと思うから
自分のレベルとしては
もうあっちゃんの youtube 大学は
おっ今まで勉強日本語の勉強にはならない
ほぼ全部わかるんだけど進撃の巨人だったら
マーナ0に二に1個ぐらい
知らない単語とか二1回学んで忘れた単語が出るから勉強に
すごく勉強になる
うん
うーん
今日は道元さん僕は se でんですね
末スウェーデン人です
日本語を勉強する難しいと楽しい
スキルは
最後
悪い
悪いん
道銀さんめっちゃ黒夜葬
とんでもないです
国会中継度日本語一番難しくて
中身がない確かにそうだよね
政治家たちの日本語って何だろう
なかなかあっ
それも暗幕を自分的にも使えないっていうか
そもそも日本人も政治家直接その聖地化等の日本語じゃなくてニュースを見て政治家が
何を話したかとかそういうのを
そうやって政策を施行
しるんじゃないかなと思うから
ほとんどの日本人でも直接政治家の話じゃなくて
ニュース見てるんじゃないかな
でありますを使いがち
うんそうだね
進撃の巨人は日本語教材だったのかうん
深尾付買おうと思えば
使えます結構
特に最後のシーズンはね
いっ
第1シーズンとかだったらちょっと難しいけど
おたおめ
電球
ほとんどの政治家は日本人じゃないということ
はーるぺ着せぬ母を
d 15バージョン s a 級ブレーカーズ nba some bc のベリア
延久 rods サブスクライブ means ビーンズスープカープで
youtube jan
メイビーターズホップ h バージョン
fedele 杖スタート4 me セキュア
んん
ウォーズ s 1000 rr と
andare voodoo ドゥア
私を日本語教師です
私の学生がみんな道元さんの動画見てますよかったです
道元さんこんにちは日本語能力試験へ
経験ありますか2級6回目
ありますけど
[音楽]
もう1回受けたいなぁと今思ってます
今までに japanese で読んだ本は何冊ぐらい何冊だろう
わかんないために20冊ぐらいかなお
ほとんどが日本人ではないがトップの9
ということ
ぷぷ voodoo はーれむ
いっ
ウィンド bcas カードリーディング sdx 4 s japanese オール
スタンディングエディターズ beru 頭痛 x panon
ディスピーカーズ d
ディバーシー人 japanese blsp キーン nba プロジェクト某 me
your
その5 en you do in
4 s カンファレンス all day カーム tendre
プロフィール by voices コーンズぬ
道
ka ブレッドマンガー進撃の巨人
名原
ザーン進撃の巨人で競ってきたターン後本当に難しいですね
やそうだねめっちゃ難しい
そんななちゅあちゅらるが日本法人
日本語は
をボーイんでも
時々無性化するからなぁ
いいとう以外の暴飲
そうだな心とかたまに
そうだな
なかなかそう
そこの教えるべきかというとそうじゃないと僕は思ってます
逆に何だろうこう
使える知識かっていうとそうでもないと思う
そこら辺だったら
あるそういう現象あるのはあるんだけど
んう
なんかこう
勉強して役立つかっていうとそそっこまで役立たないんじゃないかなと思う
[音楽]
難しい単語が出てき
何で調べますかじっしょ
うん
辞書ももしくは無視する
無声音とか雄星4
とかって
普段意識せずに喋ってるから外国人から日本語の無線ようについて質問されて初めて
気付いたりするそうだよねまあ英語でもそうなんだよね
英語の正
カーブスの s の発音は s の発音じゃなくてずっ
水の発音だってほとんどのネイティブは意識してないっていうかわかんない
ネイティブに説明したら確かにそうだってなるんだけど
一般人はそこら辺は意識してないから
ハピ2 afa 入所ん
[ __ ]ユアーちゃんなるの po アシベピュアー天気
verve カットチャーてやっててお誕生日おめでとうございます
今学校で日本語を勉強しているんですが
十年後の日本語のビデオは
外来語についての
pro
プロジェクトをするきっかけにハースきっかけとなりました
学習を楽しくしてくれてありがとうございます嫌よ嫌
いやでもまあ確かに何だろう論文とかに使えそうだなテーマとしては
道元さんはほぼ日本人日本人視聴者にも難しいいう中日本堂元さんほど日本人し当社に
もう難しいユーチューバーは居ないやそうでもないと思うんだけど
日本語で聞くと
日本語で答えてくれるんだ神じゃ yeah
どう下の好きなゲームを何ですか
こちらです
ファイナルファンタジー7
ダントツ1位です
優しいです優しい家
ん
優しい俺なんか間違えたん
優しい
ああそうだね優しい優しいん
そうだな
間違えたねっ
久しぶりにその読み方
で壊したな
6 aa
日本語を勉強しようと思ったきっかけは何ですか
なんとな角格闘技が大好きでそこから日本に興味を持つようになってそっから日本語を
勉強しようと思った
ピッチャーアクセントについて教えていただきありがとうございました
言えこちらこそ見てくれてありがとうございます
all you can 42部の林 japanese abart oono 4
ニュースずを
空手格闘技はちゃんとした場面で
学んだことはないんだよね全部散っ
独学
海外の友達から教えられて道元さんを知りました
へ逆輸入
なるほどねそういうのがあるんだね
同件はチーティングバードじゃあピースボイスアクターズワーカーはネイル名
rr japanese for sake アストロ4 s not pass と
rod スタートレックなぁウィキャンドゥ
ますばいばーー this blog this point 4 me
系格闘技から日本語って
ももう珍しそう
や意外といるんじゃないかなと思うんだよね
ファニーメイ
格闘技じゃないかな
まあアニメ
日本語自体が好きだっていう人もいるんだけどアニメ
がきっかけ j-pop がきっかけ格闘技がきっかけそういう順番じゃないかな
ハウスアワー市の pr スーパーマーケッツジョイングリー
日 cars アイヤー
10オンラインショッピング
how to さあもうナチュラー japanese
アーリーぺ着せぬディプロス ace anton added to do スポーツ
x ワンオーナー1
ハームソープパッツァ次ぐ first star
はリース北京 to do the メイクスマートパワーずつ
ブレーキ tantan ジェンナースティック see to do フリース
タワーアレックスピースワークビュア
どう下の動画って日本人にとっ
にとっても日本語見直せるめっちゃくちゃいい動画ですよね
英語がわからわかればだけど
そうだといいけどね
あんまりそこらへんを考えたことなかったねどっちかって言えば
これたまに聞かれるんだけどその視聴者のターゲットは誰ですかって聞かれたら
その調査というよりも自分が個人的に思った動画を作ってるだけだから
そういう感じで今作ってます
道元さんがワシントン
ワシントン州出身だと聞いた私も
う出身っていうか
そこで育ったんだよねぇー
生まれたのは生まれたの生まれたのは生まれ生まれたのは仮フォン
カリフォルニア州
日本のどこに住んでいますか別府別府に住んでます
道元さんどサンド
どうゲー fa カップ北京道具 not to do n でガースパーマンディ
パティンキン you do
lg スリーパーバッグ n デーざぶ place to us 4 p ボーダー
ex winter 金バッジ
レヴィディアバーキンと超ようなキャディ
なんでペップに住んでいるんですかペットですね
温泉に行きますか
たまに行きますね別府もともと東京に住んでたんだよね東京に住んでたっていうか
京葉大学に留学してそれで1年間
東京に住んでたんだよね
で
その1年間が終わったら自分のワシントン州にある大学に戻って
で最後の1年間大学の最後の1年間アメリカです
アメリカです go してその間に
者プログラムというその英語の教師教師
そういう仕事を目指してまー
履歴書とがう
書いて沿いの全部
者プログラムというものに申請してその申請する時点で希望ができるんだよね毒行き
たい場所はありますか日本行きたい場所
あったらどこです勝って以降欠けるところがあって
その時に
[音楽]
すごくなかなか良い友達日本人のパン精いっぱい入ってその1別府出身でその人に相談
したら
まあとにかくとにかくいうよりも1年間東京に住んでたし今度はもうちょっとこう
田舎じゃないけどもっとこう
まあ都会じゃないところところを言ってみればって言われて
で確かにパシカ2層の方がまあより多くよりもっともっと日本のことをもっと知れる
寿司れるんじゃないかなと思って
別府に申請して
大分危険な彼の
越冬
文豪の子っていうド田舎になっちゃった
そこからいろいろあって
別府にぱ取りついたっていう
経緯
日本の中学校とかえーるちーとか
いるのジェット便
マジで言っ
今自身の奴が来たんだけど大丈夫なのかなちょっと待って
湯布院からのお知らせ
ああそうかそうか台風か
緊急そこを
避難情報
マジで
避難情報てってた
そっか
すげえなこれ
いうふうに出るのかなーう
台風コーンの台風が来るんだよね
おいた件
うん
自信家
大雨多分台風台風で書いてあるな
同社崩れとかさ
台風9号が
上陸する恐れがあるため
しない全然
業
っていいのかなの15エッセ都営これすげーぬ
発令します避難
命令命令子だけど
発令しましたすごいなあこれちょっと怖いぬ
ファイアー c 製プレート大噴射 bokin デップ omae アプリグッズ
政府
入手
パウンドさあ種苗系
気を付けます
スマホ持ってたらエ
顔を洗っている途中にその自身のアラーム鳴ってくそ vivi
そうなるよね
hpd
hpd ってなんだっけ
ありがとうございます
定年の可能性があるから充電とかはした方がいいよねそうだよねたしかしそうだよ
おいた米も話せますか話せるていうかわかるけど普段からハナ差ない
意識意識的に
使ってない
日本語を教えているから
特にそのアークセイバーアクセントとか教えてるからー
大分弁が
高
入ってきたら自分の中に置い食べになっちゃって
その自分の生徒さんに悪いからもう大分に引っ越す前から決めたんだよね
大分に引っ越しても標準語を使うっていう
やバターんやばたんさんと仲がいいのですか
仲がいいならまたコラボして欲しい
仲いいよ僕大好き彼のこと
本当に大好きクリエーターとしてすごく尊敬しているし
まんだろう人格もすごく好き
絶対また絶対にまた動画を彼と一緒に作ります
[音楽]
日本語学者
です
文豪のは三重総合
そうだな
三重総合高校
三重三重町に住んでば
方言って知らず知らずのうちにでるからなぁそうだよね
やばたんめっちゃいい人
よーしすごく is ねーず ys 土それは
ねえぞ wise sok 冬ねーぞ i すんごく
鼻濁音していいやつ
目2 p ポッド error in cars なぁとウェーバーれプリーツタイプ
sp kno ケールねぇねぇず eyes
amatan ap japanese high school decrease
sat fax ポーズみー注入するキャプリーンソフィブースターのパンティ
ウェイバリー
[音楽]
of the epd
hpd これのんだっけ
とにかくありがとうございます
バイウェイ街下がっ中
度スターフェイスチーム4
ああ
[音楽]
oec voodoo ああああ
2 me the factor
sar タイムバーン
5なぁ it ストーリー5 exif メニュー美味しい
s 5
f フェチ est un bacio bad girls nomen name
my boo ベロベイブルー
ばい
野外中ずおいしい of time
道元さんにとって感じのいろんな組み合わせの
これの凝縮凝縮だとき
しているテキストは読みにくいと思うんでしょうか例えば
感染予防対策とか
いやーこういうのを覚えたら逆に
幹事の方がありがたい
道元さん身長高いから座っている方が腰きついらしいですよ
僕はの
背が高いからって言うよりも腰のヘルニアがあるんだよねヘルニア
道元先生こんにちはこんにちは
あを消す osf さん urore ズームマイクファーストレバーぺちゃ
surface pro japanese
air
fake star マウスウェスティン9 form for marketing
with
や水瀬月
グリーンベリーハービンがピーポーん
もう the braver ファ
だ
北家曲イズナーを
街もラバー wise スプレームーン線ホッピー d カーズ様 do do
with
ber パーペチュアル4 add the
amis ハービーダム op 部大ノーロードぺジャクソンビーカーずつ
アディツアー rbc pb 2 mip メイク this ジャバーワードて御礼
ワードベンジェンスとぅ
まだデンジャースターブルワーズ
teacher すーみん
ratebeer アーレ4 s 4 a pas her be to do on
nba マーグ
うぇい s japanese for a broader アーレスマートパス
ぼーん
son 明日 how トーンアーム exo stl プレイ
with this property nom バー5 af
ディ not to do spero tears
んですっ
パーティー none cardio renal パワーアンプ
ディネへ着くいいもうすぴーぽー兼備カー with まあ te あーおれ株数 t
you do
うーん
惜しい
道元さんは日本をで喋っ喋るとき
でどれだけ意識してるんですか笑
話題によるないようによる
例えばまあこういう会話とかだったらあまり意識してないんだけどなんだろうこう
[音楽]
難しい話とかだったら
まあ比較的意識するタイプそれ
英語でも意識するんだけどね
この前冷蔵庫のさ冊買って全く良いシャツだよ
スン
すごく好きなありがとうございますすごく嬉しいです
dare ハイフィン you do ウェイ
カー with me brandstar ユーチューバー beriru 2
pod farm ざーエロ
シャア renren japanese people who do 薄く大津の
ぬ
だーカーテンブルーティアーズネームつなぐねぇて
アークセントに対して意識したりする
おおーー
これも場合による
機といえば
[音楽]
完全に覚えたっ
今後もあればなんだったっけっていう単語もあるから
まあ本当にとにかく場合にうっ
英語を話すとき声が低くなるのがすんごくあが好きです
これはたぶん
みんなそうじゃないかなと思うっていうのは
ランサーになりましたか34歳です英語を話すときは
区域ボイスといって
この
息を出す
速さがし遅くなるんだよね
すぴーそのスピードが遅くなるから自然的に
ああ
カーっていう音が入ってくるんだよね
特に
文章の最後に
日本語だとそれがなかなかないから全くないというわけじゃないんだけど
日本語どっちかと言えばその発言の最初から最後まで
ちゃんとちゃんと t 加工
きっちり音を出すから
どっちかって言えば
その区域某エステやつあんまり出ない
日本
日本語だったらでもいい子だったら
出るだから英語の自然の発音をすると
how are you doing じゃなくてその息のある葉お湯デューイんじゃ
なくて how are you do in
ってこうちょっとちょっとだけ遅くなって
それ遅くなることによって声のそのトーンが低くなる
それがまあ英語の現象の一つだと思うんだよねいろんなことがあるから
声の質っていうのは結構根本的に違うと思ってるんだよね
web start バッグスター nec bomp 2ドゥハウ japanese
voice ピーキングパワー with deep n
ブーム正拳イング cp んスター enos
大体のい1英語を話すとき
声が低くなって日本語だと高くなりますパー各なりますよね
アメリカ人のへの友達に話したら
首かしげって
首傾げてましたん
首傾げてましたが
これいつも
早く普通に読めのいいですよね
[音楽]
冷蔵庫は走ってますか
あ
言語を変えたら冗談の
意味がなくなりましたそうまるで周遊スパローズアウター to do live mn
es 2ウォッチとムービーフロスティ
without pas d ラン2タイムズ
電話中 web サブタイローズ
マイク three four time to do with バーカー
なぁで none ファインピックアップワールドスタッフ
ゲイナー大誘拐のパーヴェル are you can be the crib 5
人
日本語にはへ
もうな
っていう概念があるからはっきり発音しないと伝わりにくいんだよ
うそうだねもうラーがあっ
日本語のリズムがすごく難しいんだよね
外国人からしたら日本語は歌運営
振りすぎる件がをな気がする
夕刊紙にしたね
私は英語を話すとき性格が変わりますが道元さんもそういう
ことを感じることはありますか
僕はそこまで正確変わらないと思うんだよね英語でも日本語でもその
向こう側向こう側が受ける印象は変わるかもしれないけど性格的に
あまり変わらないと思うんだよね英語でも日本語でも
もともとこう
ノン人だっけ控えめ控えめな性格ひかえめ
校内内向的内向的でいいのかな
ない子内向的だからグループとかなるとあまり発言しないタイプ
を音なし
考え事をしているときは英語で考えていますかとっさに出てしまうの英語ですか日本語
ですか熱いものを触った触ってしまった時とかこれも場合による
考え言葉で日本語になっている時もあれば英語になっている時も
計画が変わるのって
幼い頃に
多数言語を習った人たちの場合って感じがする
日本在住ですかそうです別府です初見ですありがとうございます
日本
日本語を話す時僕の僕の声はヤンキ
ヤンキーな感じがすると何回も言わ言われた
それはたぶんアニメとかドラマとか見すぎかもしれないです
動画終とへ
激しいの多いです
けど生品生方針はおとなしいですもねそうだよね
動画の普通の子メインの奴はもう基本的にもずっと院議員
演技だから
全然それが薄いじゃないっす数じゃない
根本的に違いますね
良い子はどれだけそれっぽく発音しても外国人の人から聞いたら
japanese
[音楽]
アクセントから抜け出してないのかなしーあこれも音声学勉強した方がいいと思う
例えば
これ日本人
よく僕の経験で言いますと
t アワーの音をきれいに発音しようとするんですよね
超わぁ簿とかとぅ web とか
長が暴徒化でも tor が一緒に来るとその t の音が
ch の音に変わることが多いんだよねだから2ワーブじゃなくて
ファーラー簿トゥラヴトゥレイプ
プラボ
からそういうちょっとしたなんだろうこうトリック
そういうのを学ぶことによってだいぶ
彼は変わると思う
あーケアー have a good グッズオプション have a
japanese class 4 sp チーム m so ディフェンダーうーん
ん
濃ピンクスノー sus 4んだろペンティア
ディアーナナナ sus 4ん
サーキュラーコメントにもなぁ奔放 scenery
アメリカポピー voice ras ペッっ
を絶つ
a dancer ヘンリーダメニーズああ
チェーンセキュリティー nodera paneled esd speak
easy to do so she 日本人4 n japanese prod
the voodoo
ぐりーんろーマーズワン
sen オンスターファイアーワークス part pasado バーナー先生
たーーー
いつかエビ cars ウィザー
動画楽しく見させてもらってます
よかったですありがとうございます音声学とナヲ子も学んだ方がいい
うーんそうだね
俺音声が来て言わなかったっけ
脳が日本語モードの時は独り言とかとっさに出てくると言葉も日本語になりますよね
ああそうだねほんとどっちになっているか
その場面によるっていうか
[音楽]
ignore the voodoo
えっ
ジェロ sp キーン ayk ゲームスターズ ore abc なリングを封印し
スイングファーム
by ronny 4 ever poor you do ポップアップじゃ
プリンス ost ファーウェイバーテン昨日見たことありますかないです
なんかちょっと見たく
これなんかこうすごく
何だろう
子供ぽい意見かもしれないけど
君の名はがっすんごく好き0
何だろう
同じ監督で同じサウンドととラッグ
radwimps ばからなんか
期待すごく期待してるんだよね天気の子
ガー同じレベルじゃないと結構がっかりすると思うんだよね
学会したくないからあえて見てないっていう
音声学やらへ
音声論やら言語各はややこしいじゃんややこしいんじゃんややこしいね
ややこしいウィッカースティックムービーとリビングメディア to do ベースと
なぁ
僕じゃなくて俺を使っているのはなぜですか
両方を使えますこれも場合による
ここだったらまあ
高
砕けた感じ
だからあんまり
まあ俺でもいいんじゃないかなと思うんだけど
y すんごくいざ九州弁ノーチェス2回の米アウディ finepix アップ防衛だ
プランスすごくいい
ss 交尾だー紺色イントロ a バレーシステムバーガーハーヴェル ipad up
to do have a sore 草プボイスとセイバー色々と合意がある
前の作品みましたかや見てないです
今アニメ
言語学習を目的した以外のアニメ
鑑賞でいいのかなちょっと僕にとっては難しい
あんまり時間がない
アイスバーニーヌ
手話氏は日か座
[音楽]
これすこれなんて言わなかったっけ
声ば聲の形
日本語の一番難しいと思うところは何ですか
今後のん一番難しいところ
道
じゃあ
たくさんありますねー
ほっとっとっうそりゃああれタイム
俺にとってはう
大経が難しいけどねアームス guys 上がる結婚
ああっ
夏目漱石女ことがありますかねないですね
残念ながらまだないですね
三島由紀夫ならありますけど
空気じゃないそうだな空気が一応難しいです
空気を読むの一番難しいです
バーガー25 pou dou dou 4秒4 ai this
ポイント集中マーチ5 japanese ウェイビア優しい難しい漢字の違い
face エンジェルアナーキーまた近いうちにまた
できるかどうかちょっとわからないんだけど出来たらまたやりたいと思いますのでまぁ
また是非来てくださいありがとうございます
それではありがとうございますまた会いましょうまた話しましょう
エピサロン等厳選さようならばいばーい
ばい
車